you're you're talking about your father
and i'm sure he's an amazing man
but every time you said
he doesn't drink he doesn't cheat
you said he's such a wonderful person
i would argue
that
if i'm honest enough to tell the truth
and i support
the other half and i kill myself trying
to make her life wonderful then i also
am an amazing person yeah and so you
weren't a good person no i'm just saying
just for because of contrast sake i'm
not upset about it okay look i get
called a piece of [ __ ] all the time so
no it's fine i mean yeah yeehaw
but what i what i am saying is like
being a good person
and being monogamous are two different
things
your father
and rolo tomasi
and donovan sharp
are a product of a zeitgeist that is
about let's say 20 30 years back
and that's where everybody came up and
believed and lived and died by the sword
of the bible mostly
that monogamy was only way if your
father being a one percenter
or rolo or donovan
were 35 now here now in 2022 with
instagram and women blowing their phone
up all day i argue
that the likelihood of them being
monogamous for 25 30 years is
substantially less not because
they're weaker not because of anything
other than
each generation faces a new set of
problems
and those gentlemen including your
father and respect
don't or never did have to face the
problems of let's say the gentleman of
today have to
face when it comes to temptation against
the natural nature of biology as a human
being
i also think it's again as i've said the
situations you choose to put yourself in
so again including the year you're born
in in the culture
no but i like because you're not
relevant if you're not on social media
right now
you're not relevant yeah like so like in
business if you're trying to like build
yourself up in business linkedin
facebook like a lot of our business card
is on our instagram how people perceive
us treat us and allow us to have
opportunity in the market yeah but you
have to understand like this is a very
different industry than what my dad does
he's fine without social media i get
metal building deals because of
instagram okay
i'm just saying i'm just saying like
like
your dad yeah he sounds like a superhero
because even he is one percent from his
time
right
but i think there's it's important that
somebody watching this understands the
distinction respectfully the distinction
between what your father chose to do
with his life and being a good person
well i just when i hear that someone
chooses to be loyal like to be entered
into a monogamous relationship with the
woman that gave him seven biological
kids three adopted and chooses to be
monogamous i just have a different level
of respect for it i just i then than
someone that chooses to like exercise
their options do you understand that
most monogamous monogamous men are not
loyal let me tell you why
the evidence doesn't really support that
if you take surveys but i think usually
the red pill is like like they're just
lying but let's talk about let's talk
about
let's talk about loyalty though okay
because most men that get married
use
marriage and monogamy as a mating
strategy to get that woman
okay so he's trading sexual exclusivity
for
and marriage
for sex
but he makes vows
that he's going to do his best to create
the most wonderful life he can for that
woman they exchange vows
and in my opinion a man's loyalty is
keeping that second part
when most men don't they come home they
pop open a beer they smoke a bowl of
weed they watch a ball game they turn on
an xbox
okay
as they do that they do not produce and
provide for their woman and i would
argue that is the most unloyal man that
you can possibly come in contact with
because he stood in front of people and
made vows to take care of her provide
for her and create an amazing life for
her and he came home and popped open a
bud light that's not loyalty no i agree
with you i i do like i always say i
think cheating is different for men and
for women i always say i i would leave
someone if they cheated unless we had
kids because if you have kids it's not
about you anymore but
i i just think it's cool like i just
respect my dad a lot for having the
option to do what he does and still
choosing to remain loyal to my mom and i
know the red pill will say forever oh
he's cheating he's cheating but but i
don't know my dad is just i respect him
a lot and i think it's really cool that
he does that i think there's a good
chance that there's a relationship that
your mother and your father have between
them that you'll never know about i'm
not saying he's cheating
but
if he did cheat
he's a damn good man from hiding it from
all of you so he can continue to paint
that picture of reality now me
i'm not going to do that because i would
rather live in truth
but if you know how they say if a tree
falls in the woods and nobody hears it
did it happen
maybe that zeitgeist that group of men
in that age range that was their
strategy now that we're in 2022
the strategy i think that it makes you
the best man shows the most character is
to just tell the truth hey just tell the
truth and don't embarrass your woman i i
agree with you but i i just don't like
the argument that like
ever because it doesn't feel good to you
no it's not that it doesn't feel good
it's that you'll believe what you
believe regardless of any evidence to
the contrary so if the evidence says
that one out of four men cheat you'll
say oh they all cheat
i would argue and it's like if i say no
my dad doesn't cheat he doesn't do that
you say well he probably has an
arrangement with your mom behind the
scenes because i'm not saying that i'm
not saying that i'm saying there's a
chance you you just you just implied
that which is fine like i understand
that's your world view but i just grew
up around like
i would say like the men of value versus
high value men which is just like the
type of men that kind of get their money
get their woman go buy a piece of land
and don't want to talk to anybody and
it's just a very different like world
than the like one that you guys live in
and that's partially what brought me
into the red pill because i was like
this is what you think high value men
are like right and that's kind of what
i'm arguing yeah because because you're
just you're putting
certain life choices with value as a
person
and i'm simply saying what created value
in his time and certainly in your life
because obviously you've turned out very
very well
him being valuable in that time and him
having that good impact on you is
incredible
i'm just simply arguing that
a man that in 2022 that tells the truth
takes care of his business takes care of
his family shows up for his wife in the
most important ways providing truly
loving her making sure that her life is
a [ __ ] carpet ride and then loving
the [ __ ] out of the kids and supporting
and doing the right thing that a man
should do because a man does have the
burden of performance and i put that
burden of performance
right there in the loyalty spot in the
turning up for your family that is a
good man
not whether you had sex with another
woman or whatever you know it's the
lying
it's the deceit that hurts so badly
and the reason that women are unhappy
is because the formula for happiness is
the gap between expectation and reality
yeah your father gave that to your
mother that's what made him a good man
for me i would rather not lie because
the world has changed since your father
was a father and from when i will be a
father so i'm gonna be brave enough bold
enough to love and be impactful enough
to tell the truth and you can leave if
you want
but if you leave me for a man you love
lest when i told you the truth you have
to respect that i tell you the truth and
then i back up what i said and that
loyalty is producing performing
providing and being who you say you are
but she might not want to know like that
stuff
i think that once just like your
situation
i think if it's said once it never has
to be said again as long as you respect
it enough not to try to dig poke pry
well just so just justin
sure yeah
so so you you wouldn't then subscribe to
the sort of keeping an unspoken kind of
fight because obviously you present
because you present obviously very high
value guy you're you're obviously gonna
present to somebody who's got
right options and the ability to do this
when you're with a woman so do you even
need to have that conversation i think
it's unethical not to have the
conversation at least once
cool what i mean like is it a situation
where like she would already know in
your course or you would just say
straight away this is this is what i
want to be doing into the relate i think
that i think that you need to give a
woman the opportunity to really get to
know you as a human and as a person
before you
have that conversation and the reason is
is a lot of women will stop seeing a man
they could have loved that could have
went right
because of this subject yeah but look at
your relationship right and i mean this
with complete respect there's a gap
between you and him
you were talking about it earlier you
know that he's seeing other women that's
creating that's creating distance
between you
when you could just talk about it one
time i didn't say i know that he is i
don't know you said that you have a
problem
yeah there's there's a high chance right
there's a really high chance but
i
i
it just hurts too much to even like
bring that up then write him a note do
something because i'm telling you what
you're costing yourself
is if he feels guilt about it and i
promise you he does especially in the
western world
then what's happening is he's only
loving you to a certain degree
and he's protecting himself because he's
worried that if he gets caught you're
going to leave but if you could just
snap that and let him know that you
already know because you clearly already
know if you could just let him have that
you would be shocked at how much more
capacity to love you he would have
because he would be able to trust that
he can love you fully yeah can i get
that but it's just you know you get it
but it doesn't feel good you're scared
of it yeah it doesn't do it then
then be that bold and fix it it doesn't
feel good and you have given me
something to think about for sure but
for my situation like we're talking
about parents like my dad was so much
like paul's dad um yeah my dad actually
looks like you
did
my dad
my dad isn't a hero
but you know my parents my my my parents
are no longer here like i'm not i'm not
a girl with a big business i don't earn
a lot of money
like
this like my situation is different
where like he provides everything for me
i'm lucky i don't want to
invite any kind of just yeah it doesn't
feel good and if you
had if you had to bet money
on whether he's cheating or not cheating
what would you put your money on and i
have a follow-up question about that
life or death i think this is a bit much
no i don't think it no no i think it's
completely fair if you think dude
you have to answer
like i have a feeling because i'm aware
because i'm just aware that the type of
guy he is he's not he gets attention
from women everywhere we go but he's a
very very private person i think that's
what like helps the situation because it
makes you feel better because you think
he's private and you don't have to talk
about it
but if you had to bet you said three
times you think he is right
but why don't why do i have to bring
that up
because it's bothering you
it's bothering you and again i think
that if you guys took this
situation it's a wedge it's a wedge
because you know what's happening right
and i'm not trying to be ugly in fact if
anything i'm trying to be hopeful to you
no i can hear that like i'm not i'm not
trying to i'm not trying to make a point
i'm simply telling you i've experienced
this i've been with a girl that didn't
know
okay and i felt like i couldn't tell her
and because i felt like i couldn't tell
her
i would hold back like a piece of my
heart
because i was terrified that if i gave
her the whole thing and she caught me
then it would wreck me
and i'm telling you that's a that's a
wedge
and that you could stop did she ever
bring up with you did you ever tell her
i ended up sitting her down and telling
her
and she didn't leave
are you still with her are you still
with her wouldn't you like to know
so no
sterling sterling do i no no no way you
know what to help you hold on hold on to
help you
yes i am and sterling knows her well
i've been with her for a while yes she's
madly in love with him yeah okay for a
long time she's the most amazing woman
but the thing is is that like it is i
understand that but she won't want to
talk about that stuff with you like i'm
not i i even if she does like we joke
about it all the time like it's so
because but here's the thing that but
here but hear me out here no i'm i'm
genuinely trying to help you like you're
obviously a sweetheart we've been
talking to instagram for what six months
about going on your show
like what bothers me about this for you
is like when you're you're scared
is what you're what's happening you're
scared but just like jumping out of an
airplane or doing a big business deal
the more times you touch it the less
thing it is going to have to you yeah
but i don't want to sit there i know you
i know you don't want to but
unfortunately it's a rock in your shoe
which is a rock in the relationship and
it's stopping you and him
from going to this place where you don't
talk about something that's super
uncomfortable to getting to like here
but is it though because i just i just
feel i don't want like you're sitting
there saying you you sit there with your
with your partner and you talk about
these things and you laugh about it i
wouldn't be laughing about it okay no no
i i don't think you will and neither
were we in fact there there was a time
where
every time i've told a girl this they
leave for like a week
and what they really do is go
compartmentalize it and really unpack it
and really try to make their mind up and
what what i'm telling you is
is if you and him were able to have that
understanding and not speak of it
anymore and you released that guilt or
that burden and that fear of losing you
from him
you would get closer
and i think you would be likely to never
lose him because of it because very few
women can see the world for how it
actually is do you like it no do you
want a man that's going to cheat on you
no
will you accept it you're already
accepting it so why not take the
benefit of getting the information
that's going to make your love deeper
because what you're really not accepting
is him as a man because men are this way
and i don't say that to make a point i
say it because it's true he wants to
love you more
he can't because he's scared of what
he's going to lose if you see who he
really is and he can't bring the truth
to you i'm trying to do that
tell him
i i just feel that everything is is fine
with us
how it is like
it's amazing you're scared
you're scared it's not amazing because
you're scared he's cheating on you or
you don't like that feeling in your gut
because you don't want to give him full
permission because maybe somewhere he's
not he is you already know you've said
it four or five times maybe i don't know
so why don't you watch your position by
having the conversation with him and let
him know that you love him so much
you're not gonna leave okay
for example if i had that conversation
with him he might put a ring on your
finger and he no but and he wasn't there
and he wasn't doing that that's
basically giving him a card to go yeah
i'm just gonna he's gonna do it anyway
the difference is is he gonna love you
at 110 percent or is he going to love
you at 75. i'm not sure it is absolutely